Bethesda Gary Steinman the Global
Content lead on Bethesda's blog just
released something that's of interest to
us three especially who review games a
lot Pete your the reviews editor but
that was saying you know like early in
the year doom we got review copy what a
day early mm-hmm and people are
speculating maybe that means the game
itself is gonna like suck or whatever
they were saying on Twitter and it
turned out to be a really good game and
that like kind of led to more
conversations around I know like 2k the
publisher our last few releases hasn't
really given us the games that early in
advance at all so it's kind of as
reviewers doesn't give us as much time
but a lot of people keep thinking this
means that you know these games are not
going to be great because they're not
giving the reviewers like two weeks in
advance to play them right but um no but
that's just saying that's just how it
works now you want to talk about that a
little bit like that you read through
the blog post I have it up now I can
kind of quote it if you want but yeah I
mean throw a quick quote out there like
I think just to sort of give their their
aim um so yes on the blog it says with
the upcoming launches of Skyrim special
edition in dishonor to both of which
Bethesda will be publishing we will
continue our policy of sending media
review copies one day before release
while we will continue to work with the
media streamers and youtubers support
their coverage both before and after
release we want everyone including those
in the media to experience our games at
the same time right okay so yes people
might assume these these games are bad
but when a company says all our games
are going to be handled this way that
immediately doesn't really make sense
that kind of conclusion I mean the best
conclusion you could really make here is
that I don't think these companies are
scared of bad reviews but I think that
they are willing to take sort of more of
the control over the messaging around
something be a good or bad and yeah it
can suck for a lot of reasons for us as
reviewers given it's our job and it
definitely can suck for a lot of
consumers who rely on reviews to buy
games like there's no question this
doesn't do anything for the consumer
this is a thing that really just
benefits Bethesda so you may see it
change some of the ways that DM games
are reviewed because obviously we can't
review a 20-hour game after one day so
they'll be maybe some different types of
coverage around that I mean we've got to
figure that out and Bethesda might
follow suit or other companies might
follow in Bethesda's footsteps so who
knows but I think it's interesting to
say the least and will certainly make
our jobs very different yeah cuz I was
gonna say like looking back at recent
examples Scott you reviewed both these
games yeah lofi earlier this
consider this past weekend because of
which were published by 2k and so that's
kind of like there's a shocking
disparity between them because you know
a mafia 34 as many good things that did
we talk about a lot but guy you gave it
a six and I think like overall dislike
regardless of the scores it was very
much like it was kind of on the lower
end especially like technical value so
that's kind of like one of the games
that people would assume would be
released or like giving us code like the
day before but then sieve six comes out
and you love that we're gonna talk about
it briefly the score itself briefly in a
little bit but across the board people
are really liking either say it's one of
the better entries in the series and
whatnot so it's kind of a huge
juxtaposition between those and you kind
of saw the in terms of time management
you saw like them the heart and I both
of those as be pointed out we can't
review certain games you know in given
one day lead time like sieve is way too
big and mafia turned out was like a 40
hours year as well so trying to review
that in a daze quite literally
impossible there just aren't enough
hours in the day as the saying goes but
also if you just pointed out the
disparity between the qualities of sieve
and mafia sort of calls him to question
that prevailing narrative that Oh
getting a game late means it's going to
be bad because in Mafia's case yeah
there were definitely some technical
problems on every platform so that kind
of validated that that theory right that
all you got you forget a lady Vince is
going to be bad but sieve I mean aside
from a few problems maybe with the AI
which I experienced less than other
people actually but aside from that
there were no real problems the game is
great there's there was no real reason
for them to hold back in terms of look
you know concerns about quality like
they they had to have known it was a
really good game and it is yeah so yeah
I'm actually with Pete that I think that
I don't know to me this decision by
Bethesda doesn't necessarily serve
consumers but at the same time I think
it just reflects natural shifts in the
landscape I mean youtubers and then that
type of thing that's it's a thing now
right like the media is not the only
option for four games coverage so us not
getting the games as early as we used to
in my mind is just a reflection of the
times and the way things work and it was
always a privilege to get games ahead of
time there a commercial product and it
was we were very fortunate to get stuff
early but I don't we were ever entitled
to yeah so
yeah yeah and look at kind of just enjoy
quick look at the Final Fantasy 15 right
like we got 50 access to like over a
dozen hours of that game like a month
ahead a launch that's pretty beefy for
previews yeah maybe this will just
change the way the previews are handled
yeah it's gonna be a good thing sure and
then looking back at 2k with both and
this is both for access game as well
with civ 6 and XCOM 2 we both
essentially had for both those i review
x time to skated 66 we essentially had
access to almost the whole game minus
like I forget like a few features next
time too and of course you can't review
it based on those builds alone because
they don't have everything that could
kind of change the formula they also you
know like seven have all the leaders
possible but still like you said maybe
that's changing how coverage is done
people probably see more reviews in
progress a little more often it will
obviously with Bethesda games and with
2k games you know like EA recently we've
done a couple yay reviews recently a
twenty titanfall 2 I just did and I did
the event and that was well in advance
of the review embargo yesterday
Activision had a call of duty event
recently in our view hasn't even gone up
yet so we have time with certain
publishers and I don't know it's just
kind of like you said an indicator of
how things are changing yeah this is
doing weird thing though with EA early
access like that's for battlefield and I
mean you know it goes up the week ahead
of its stated launch but only for people
who subscribe to EA access but of course
we can do that and so it's weird every
publisher does it in different ways but
clearly it's changing for everybody then
like not to mention betas and alphas and
stress tests and close out as in closed
beta and whatnot yeah yeah you mentioned
them I know
you
you